[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي العيال اختيار استهلوها بابرس
العناوين
بمدافع عن ودبابات غربيه الجيش الاوكرانيه
يحشد على طقوم خرسان واشنطن تدفعوا كلاب
للتفاوض مع موسكو
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه في الميدان اطلاق
نار على المتظاهرين وفي البرلمان مطالبات
باعدام المشاركين
[موسيقى]
كمان 48 ساعه على بدء الانتخابات النصفيه
في امريكا شعبيته اوباما لانقاذ
الديمقراطيين وترامب يعدوا بفوز جمهوري
كبير
قمه المناخ في مصر تدرجوا لاول مره تعويضه
دول الفقيره المتضرره وجدال حول من سيدفع
فواتيرها
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات الميدانيه المتعلقه
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه افاد مفرد
العربيه ان القوات الروسيه نفذت تسعه عشره
غار جويه 75 هجوما على البنيه التحتيه في
35 بلده ومدينه في شرقيه وجنوبي البلاد
خلال 24 ساعه في مقامه القوات الاوكرانيه
باستهداف سته معاقل للقوات الروسيه وموقعا
لمنظومه صواريخ مضاده للطائرات حيث اشار
الجيش الاوكراني الى ان الجيش الروسي قصف
مدينه باخمد بالدبابات والمدفعيه وقامت
باجلاء السكان قصرا من خيرسون مع تدميري
ابراج الاتصالات وانقطاع الكهرباء بعد ضرب
سد خرسان بصوارخ اوكرانيه وواصلت القوات
الروسيه القصف على مناطق حدوديه مع
اوكرانيا في منطقتي صومي
اربعه منازل في اوبلاس بمنطقه دنيا دنيا
القصر الروسيه
[موسيقى]
على جبهتي خرسه في الجنوب يحصد الجيش
الاوكراني ارتالا من القوات المدفعيه
ليؤكد مره اخرى اعتماد كلاب كبيره على
سلاح المدفعيه خصوصا الغربيه من هو ذلك
لقلب موازين الحرب ضد الجيش الروسي الذي
خسر عشرات البلدات والقرى على الجبهات
المشتعله
الهجمات بالصواريخ والمسيرات الانتحاريه
يراها الغرب علامه على تراجع الروسي في
المعارك على الارض وفي المقابل تحكم روسيا
قبضتها يوما بعد يوم على المقاطعه التي
ضمتها مؤخرا في جنوب اوكرانيا وشرقها في
ما تبقى خرف مفتاح المواجهه خلال الايام
المقبله
الدلائل كثيره فقد بدات اوكرانيا في تحشيد
قواتها على طقوم خرسون مركزه على المدفعيه
مثل قاذفته هيمارس ومدفعي ام 270
الامريكيين ومادهما 80 كيلومترا
ومدفعي ام
777 البريطاني الصنع ومده 40 كيلو مترا
هذا المدفع كانت شركه بي اي اي سيستمز قد
اوقفت تصنيعه منذ فتره ولكن تسربت مؤخرا
اشارات عن تفكيرها في تصنيعه من جديد نظرا
للنجاحات التي نتجت عن استخدامه في
اوكرانيا كيف لا تستخدم فقط منظومات
مدفعيه غربيه بل تلقت كذلك دعما من
سلوفاكيا بمدفع سوزانه وبولندا التي قدمت
الكيف مدفع اكراب وكلاه ماذاتي الحركه
روسيا من جهتها مصممه على استراتيجيه
استهداف اكثر البنا التحتيه الاوكرانيه
حيويه وخاصه المتعلقه بالطاقه لاجبار
اوكرانيا على التراجع وحتى الان يثق كل من
الجانبين بقدرته على الحسمه بينما تبتعد
فرص التفاوض العربيه
نفع السلطات الاوكرانيه الاخبار التي تم
تداولها مؤخرا حول وجود مخطط اوكرانيه
لاجلاء سكان العاصمه كياف خلال فصل الشتاء
بعد استهداف روسيا منشات كبيره للطاقه هذه
الاخبار طبعا اوردتها صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
بعدما بات شبح انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وفقدان منظومه الامداد بالطاقه بشكل كامل
عن العاصمه هاجسا يقرق السلطات العربيه
[موسيقى]
يبدلون قصار جهدهم لكي تكون المدينه من
دون تدفئه وكهرباء وامدادات المياه وبشكل
عام يريدون منا جميعا نموت هذه هي مهمتهم
يعتمد هذا على مدى قدرتنا على الصمود وعلى
مدى استعدادنا لسنر يوهات مختلفه يعتمد
مستقبل بلدنا ومستقبل كل مواطن على مستوى
الاستعداد لذا يجب ان نكون مستعدين
مع تراجعي بعض الدول الاوروبيه عن دعم
اكياس المساعدات العسكريه بدات الولايات
المتحده ترسل تحت الطاوله رسائل الى كيف
من اجل حذفها على التفاوض مع موسكو حيث
ذكرت صحيفه واشنطن بوستنا اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن شجعت سرا قاده اوكرانيا
على التعبير عن انفتاحهم على التفاوض مع
روسيا والتخلي عن رفضهم العلني للمشاركه
في محادثات السلامه ونقلت الصحيفه عن
مسؤولين في الاداره الامريكيه ان الطلب لا
يهدف الى الضغط على اوكرانيا للجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات بل محاوله محسوبه لضمان
ان تحافظ كاف على دعم دول اخرى وقالت
الصحيفه ان المسؤولين الامريكيين ايدوء
موقف نظرئهم الاوكرانيين بان بوتن ليس
جادا في الوقت الحالي بشان المفاوضات
في روسيا بوتين يحول بلاده رويدا رويدا
الى كوريا الشماليه ثانيه وفق تقرير
نشراته صحيفه فاينان شيلد تايمز
البريطانيه والتي اشارت فيها الى سياسه
داخليه جديده تقود الديمقراطيه في روسيا
وتنذر بتحول سياسي وماساه انسانيه لطاقات
البشريه في البلاد ما يعني ان الرئيس
الروسي بلادي مير بوتين قد يحوله بلاده في
المرحله المقبله الى نموذج كوريا الشماليه
وفق الصحيفه البريطانيه هذه السياسه
الداخليه الجديده تشمل عسكره المجتمع
وسيطره الدوله على الاقتصاد وعزل البلاد
والهدف واحد وهو احداث تحول جوهري في
السياسه الروسيه حيث اشارت الصحيفه ايضا
الى احتفالات ويوم الوحده الذي كان في
الرابع من نوفمبر الماضي والذي اتخذه بوت
سبيلا لتعظيم الذات والاذكاء الروح
القوميه
اعطاء اتجاه جديد للكريم يعزز انشاء دوله
استبداديه وفقه مراقبين غربيين خصوصا وان
قيام الكريم باغلاق ووقف انشطه المنظمات
غير الحكوميه المستقله واستخدام كاميرات
المراقبه لتعقب المتهربين من التجنيد دليل
يعزز توجهات ونوايا بوتن غير المعلن عنها
وهنا اشار متابعون للتطورات الحاصله الى
ان الوقت حان للقوه الغربيه للتعامل
بصرامه وذكاء مع تحركات موسكو شديده خصوصا
وانها تسير في اتجاه جاع لروسيا كتكوريا
الشماليه ولكن كبرى ذات ترسانه عسكريه تضم
الالاف من الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه فبوتن
الذي اقام وقام بضم الاقاليم الاوكرانيه
الاربعه واعلن عن التعب العسكريه الجزئيه
لتدارك الاذلال العسكري الذي عاشته القوات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره يواجه مشكله كبيره تتمثل في عدم
للطرق قواتها على الاراضي التي قام بضمها
لروسيا وهذا يعني انه لا يستطيع القيام
باي تسويه ما لم يطرد الاوكرانيين من تلك
الاراضي وايقاف كلها جماعتها
[موسيقى]
ذكر مسؤول غربي الامريكيه اوكرانيا قد
تنتهي قريبا بالتفاوض ياتي ذلك في وقت
ذكرت صحف امريكيه ان واشنطن تدفع بكياف
سرا نحو التفاوض مع موسكو فيما افاد بيان
المفوضيه الاوروبيه بان رئيسه المفوضيه
ارسله فوندر لاين بحثت مع الرئيس
الاوكراني ميرسي سبل مواجهه ما وصفته
بالدور السلبي الذي لعبته ايران بدعممها
لروسيا في عمليتها العسكريه على اوكرانيا
ووافقه البيان فان الجانبين ناقشه ايضا
تشديد العقوبات على روسيا التي تشن عمليه
عسكريه في اواخر في اوكرانيا منذ اواخر
فبراير شباط الماضي كما اكدت انها ستقطر
هذا الاسبوع حزمه ماليه كبيره من الاتحاد
الاوروبي تصل قيمتها الى واحد فاصله خمسه
مليار يورو شهريا لتغطيه احتياجات
اوكرانيا تمويليه للعامل القادم
ينضم الينا من لندن عبرس سكايب روبرت فوكس
الباحث في الشؤون العسكريه والامنيه
ابدا من النقطه التي كنا نتحدث عنها وهو
تحويل اييي روسيا الى كوريا الشماليه ولكن
اكبر هنا نتحدث عن عزلها عن العالم عن
هوامش الحريات التي قضى عليها بوتر وعن
التعبئه العسكريه هو تعبير مجازي طبعا
بسبب يعني الاختلاف بين الدولتين ولكن هل
سيسمح له الشعب الروسي بذلك
على المدى الطويل
اولا لابد له من الحفاظ على البلاد مكتمله
وان يقوم باعاده التسليح اي بمعنى انه يجب
ان يقوم باعاده تسليحه واعاده تدريب
وتجديد الجيش اذا ما كان له ان ينتصر في
المناطق التي كان قد زعم ظمها له
ويعتمدوا على دولتين في الفتره الحاليه
بالنسبه للمساعده
الخارجيها كوريا الشماليه فيما يتعلق
بامدادات المدفعيه وبدائل للقذائف
والصواريخ وغيرها
وايران بالمقابل يبدو ان روسيا لعلها
سوف تطلب كافه
المنتجات التي تقوم ايران بتصنيعها ولا
سينما تلك التي تستخدم في الميدان
التكتيكي من المسيره
بالمناطق بمنطقه خرسون بالتحديد وما يعني
تحويل هذا الى حزام امني بالمرحله المقبله
هل ستنجح بها روسيا
بطريقه محدده اي بطريقه تساعدهم على المدى
القصير
لكن هذا لن يعود بالنفع للهدف الاستراتيجي
للحفاظ والاستيلاء على جزء كبير من
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك الجزء الاكبر من
سواحل البحر الاسود وخيرسون بيحددتها
تسمى سياسه الارض المحروقه اي دمار كامل
بحيث يتم تدمير كل شيء وافراغي المدينه من
سكانها وسلفا البنا التحتيه بما في ذلك
امدادات المياه وسدود يبدو انها تعرضت
للهجوم روسيا اتهمت اوكرانيا بانها قامت
بتفجير
السد الرئيسي خارطه
بالاضافه الى ما نسمعه من الجانب
الاوكراني بان الروس هم الذين قاموا بفعل
ذلك ولكن وهذه لكن تحتها خطين قد تكونوا
خيرسون هي المكان الاساسيه اللي امدادات
المياه اللي شبه جزيره القرم اذا ما تم
اطباق هذا صار واتدمر من خلال المقاربه
روسيا يمكن تقويدي قدره روسيا
وسيطرتها على شبه جزيره القرم التي كانت
تضعف منذ عده اشهر
يعني موضوع التفوق الروسي بالمدفعيه
بالرغم من الدعم الغربي اليوم هل يمكن ان
يؤثر على قدرات موسكو
وايضا يعني
بخصوصيات هذه المنطقه
همم
هي التي تتمتعه بالفوقيه وهذا وهذا وهذه
الفوقيه ليس بسبب بالاسلحه او بسببها
التصويريف
الاقمار الصناعيه المستخدمه واستخدامي
المسيارات والاجهزه
الحربيه الالكترونيه
بكميات كبيره
الاسبقيه لكنها قد فقدت اعدادا كبيره من
اسلحتها منذ فبراير ولا تستطيع ان تستمر
بهذا التوجه
على الدوام من التقاء
اخيرا
للمدفعيه مساله اخرى بكل تاكيد بانهم
يقومون
باطلاق صواريخ المدفعيه فلفل تحدث مثلا عن
حاولتس او
غيرها ونعلم ان كل من الطرفين يعانين من
مساله نقصد اخيرا
ويجدون صعوبه في استبدال هذه الاسلحه
بسرعه
هناك حاله من الارهاق الذي طرفين شكرا لك
يا استاذ روبرت فوكس الباحث في الشؤون
العسكريه والامنيه على هذه المداخله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا سانتقل الى ايران وهذه الصور
لاطلاق رصاص في مروان في كردستان ايران
بعد المظاهرات التي خرجت هناك
اذا سنعود للصور فورا جهوزها طبعا هذه
التظاهرات كانت قد بدات اليوم منذ الصباح
هذه التظاهرات التي لم تهمد منذ شهرين
وحتى اليوم بالرغم من كل محاولات الحدث
[تصفيق]
اصدر 217 برلمانيا في ايران بيان المشتركا
وصفه فيه المحتاجين بالمجرمين وطالب
القضاء باعدامهم وذلك بعد ما هاجم
المحتجون في ايران مكتب احد البرلمانيين
واعلن برلمانيون اخرون عن تعرضهم للضرب من
قبل المتظاهرين هذا وكانت الانباء الوارده
من مدينه مروان باقليم كردستان افادت
بخروج احتجاجات حاشده حيث ردد المتظاهرين
تطالب باسقاط النظام بينما اطلق عناصر
الامن النار على المتظاهرين
في ايران ايضا الاحتجاجات متواصله رغم
الحملات القمعيه التي ينفذها نظام خامنئي
في حق المتظاهرين من اعتقالات ومداهمات
وقطع الانترنت عن رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الحكومه الايرانيه تقف عاجزه
امام الزخم الكبير للمظاهرات التي تعم كل
ارجاء البلاد منذ مقتل مهساينه حيث كان
لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي دور كبير في نشر
رساله المتظاهرين وتوثيق الاحداث وايضا
توجيه اهداءات لكل الايرانيين للخروج
والتعبير عن حرياتهم فحركت الاحتجاجات
الاخيره في ايران تعتبر الاضخم منذ عقود
ولافت للنظر فيها هو ان من يخرج الى
الشوارع هم في المقام الاول ايرانيون
ايرانيات من جيل الشباب استخدام فئه
الشباب الايراني وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
منهم قدرات تحليليه افضل كما مناحهم من
الصلاه تعبير عن مطالبهم وشجاعه للتصريح
بارائهم فوفقا للارقام الرسميه الصادره عن
صحيفه جاف اليوميه الايرانيه فان 93% من
المحتاجين تقل اعمارهم عن الخامسه
والعشرين وقد انتشرت المظاهرات الهائله في
طول البلاد وعرضها من خلال بعض مقاطع
الفيديو التي وافقت ما لا يقل عن 300
احتجاج في ايران وفقه مصادر غربيه في
المقابل امتصطع السلطات في الحد من
استخدام الانترنت رغم انها قامت بقطعه عده
مرات الى خلق الحركه الاحتجاجيه في مهدتها
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا انتقل رايكم مجددا الى ايران
وهذه الصور التي وردت قبل قليل من حي
الصديقيه بطهران العاصمه ايضا احتجاجات
الليليه في العاصمه طهران
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى اسرائيل واصدق عوده بنيامين نتنياهو
للسلطه في اسرائيل لم تقتصر على الداخل
فقط فهي تسمع الان في الداخل الايراني
ايضا كيف لا وهو الذي توعد قبل رحيله
الاخير وحتى قبل مجيئه الحلي بان سياسته
تجاه ايران كعدوا لن تتغير ابدا وان
برنامجها النووي سيكون هدفا دائما والان
وبعد عودته يفكر نتنياهو
بخطط لاتخاذ اجراءات ضد المنشات النوويه
خلال فتره ولاياتها المقبله بينها ضرب
وتدمير تلك المنشات ومنعه من التواصل الى
اتفاق النووي مع طهران وفقا لصحيفه
اجراءات ردع اسرائيلي لابد منه ان يتخذها
امام الاستسلام وامامه ابتلاك ايران
المحتمل لسلاح النووي وهو الامر طبعا الذي
تواعد زعيم اللكود فيها لطهران قبل ايام
بانه لم يحصل مهما كلف الامر لكن هناك
ايضا ادوات اخرى قد يتخذها نتنياه ايقافه
البرنامج مثل الهجوم عن بعد او الهجمات
السبرانيه او خطط التخريب واغتيال عملاء
طهران النوويين مثل النوع الذي نصب الى
اسرائيل في الماضي مهامه يا هولندا تنتهي
عند منع ايران من امتلاك سلاح نوويه اذا
ان هناك ثمه تهديد ايرانيه على الحدود
تماما وهو وجود ميليشيات طهران في سوريا
وتواهلها على الحدود فمن ذو بدء الاحداث
في سوريا في العام 2011 كان الشاغل الاكبر
لتل ابيب جناح المحاوله المستمر من قبل
ايران للانشاء البنيتها التحتيها العسكريه
في سوريا وتدمير طرق امداد مليش حزب الله
من صواريخ مواجهه بدقه ويرجح طبعا ان يعود
نتنياهو لاتباع هذه السياسه مجددا بل
تعزيزها ايضا برفع وتيره القصف الجوي
والصاروخي لسوريا خصوصا وانها خفت من
بعتها ولا يستبعد مراقبه اسرائيليون
تواغلا بريا محدودا لمنع اقترا بميشه
ايران الحدود الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من القدس عبر سكايب الدكتور
مائير استاذ العلوم المصري استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه استاذ مئير
يعني اذا ما تحدثنا عن التغييرات التي
ممكن ان ينتجها نتنياهو بالسياسه الخارجيه
مزيد من التشدد بالملف الايراني ولكن لا
يمكن الحديث عن تغيير جذري خصوصا ان
العنوان اليوم بالسياسه الامريكيه هو امن
الطاقه بالشرق الاوسط ماذا يعني ذلك
تحياتي لك يا استاذتي الكريمه وتحياتي
لجميع من يشاهدنا لا شك في النادي الاهلي
سوف يكون هناك تغيرا جذريا ولو طرا على
الساحه تغير فسوف يكون بسبب التغير على
الساحه على الساحه ولكن ليس بسبب مدينه
ياه او عوده الاكثر من سبب السبب الاول هو
ان الحكومه السابقه او الائتلاف السابق
ساره على النهج المتابعه من قبل حكومه
المتعاقبه فيما يتعلق بالقضايا الامنيه
الكبرى في المنطقه وعلى راسها طبعا قضيه
اا قضيه النووي الايراني النقطه الثانيه
وان حكومه حكومه الفتره الثانيه من
الحكومه المنتهيه ولاياتها وهي فتره كانت
في هذه المرحله الحكومه تسير اعمال وطبعا
وفقا للعرفه الدستوري المتتابعه في
اسرائيل همم حينما تكون الحكومه حكومه
تسير اعمال رئيس الوزراء يتخذ كل القرارات
المتعلقه بالامن القومي بالتشارك وتشاور
مع رئيس المعارضه
وبالتالي ميتنياهو كان شريكا في جميع
القرارات التي اتخذت في الاربع اشهر
الفائته وت- لن يكون هناك التغير كبير
تغير جزئي لا اعلم مستوى احتواء الخطر
الميليشيوي الايراني على الاراضي السوريه
من ناحيه وليس في ولا ولا في موضوع
الايراني
نتوقع استمرار سياسه التشدد على المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه صحيح
هذا صحيح انا لا اعتقد انه سوف يكون هناك
توهه البري الاسرائيلي لان لا توجد حاجه
لذلك ولكن سوف يكون هناك طبعا الاستمرار
في محاوله توطيد العلاقه مع الشريك الجار
الروسي بحكم طبعا ال- همم تواجد الروسي
على اراضي السوريه وان هو الاجواء السوريه
هي في يد طرف الروسي وهناك اليوم في اطار
الجيش السلاح الجو الاسرائيلي هناك مكتب
للتنسيق مع الجيش الروسي على اراضي
السوريه وهذا التنسيق هو على اعلى مستوى
وهو مستمر رغم طبعا التباين في او اوجه
النظر فيما يتعلق بالازمه الاوكرانيه
وبدايه
انخفاض وتيره النشاط الاسرائيلي في سوريا
في الاشهر الفائته ليس له علاقه على
الاطلاق بالحرب الاخرانيه هو انما بالظروف
على الساحه السوريه
مع احتمال كبير لخساره الديمقراطيين
الاسبوع المقبل هذا يعني ان الملف النووي
سيبقى مؤجل بالرغم من ان اداره لافيد ايضا
كانت رضا لعوده اتفاقنا وبالتالي لا نتوقع
اتفاق نووي بالمرحله المقبله
ايضا نتحدث بشكل واضح انه هو الاحداث التي
تعيش ايران اليوم هي مشجعه للغايه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل وبالنسبه لاطراف عديده في
المجتمع الدولي التي تعتقد انه ربما
الانتظار يكون افضل ربما
يحدث يجد جديد على ساحه الايرانيه طبعا
وبعد ما عاشته المنطقه من ثورات في السابق
نحن نعمل انه ربما يكون هناك تغير في
ايران ولكن على ايه حال انا اعتقد انك
استمراريه في الخطبه رفض للمفاوضات
العباسيه من الحياه ومن ناحيه اخرى
استعداد اللي هي القيام بعمل عسكري كبير
ان لم يجد جديد وان استمر نظام الايراني
في الاقتراب من الحصول على السلاح النوويه
شكرا لك يا دكتور مصري استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه حدثنا
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
من عمق المحيط الهادئ جزر سليمان تتحول
الى ملعب التنافسي الدولي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اما الان مشاهدينا فائده
امريكا وملفه في الانتخابات النصفيه
[موسيقى]
ذكرت وكاله رويترز انا العاملين في مراكز
الاقتراع المبكر في ولايه اريزونا يواجهون
تحديدات عنيفه بلغت اشدها قبل يومين من
الانتخابات
عبر البريد الالكتروني وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تتعلق بنشر المعلومات الشخصيه
عبر الانترنت مع زياده حده التنافس بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين وبحسب روترس تم
الابلاغ عن 140 تهديدا خلال شهر واحد فقط
لموظفي مكتب الانتخابات وكتب فيها عباره
سيتم اعدامكم جميعا
يستنجد الديمقراطيون اليوم بالرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما لانقاذهم من
خساره استحقاق التجديد النصفي بعد ما بينت
استطلاعات رئيس تنام حظوظ الجمهوريين في
تحقيق فوز كبير في الثامن من نوفمبر لذلك
توجب توجه الديمقراطيين الى الرئيس
الامريكي رقم 44 لانقاذ مرشح حيث اكد
متابعون لتطورات الحاصله ان اوباما لا
يزال يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره حتى في اوساط
الناخبين في المناطق التي توصف بانها
متارجحه بين الاحمر والازرق متفوقا حتى
على بقدر حيث حتى اوباما انصاره على عدم
السماح للمخاوف بشان الاقتصاد
والديمقراطيه وقضايا اخرى بدعهم الى فك
الارتباط مع الحزب في اعتراف بالتحديات
التي يواجهها الديمقراطيون على المستوى
الوطني
وشاله اوباما ثلاث ولايات تعد ساحات معركه
بين الحزبين على مدى يومين لح بتدعم ليه
الطامحين في مجلس الشيوخ وحكام الولايات
في سباقات صعبه
[موسيقى]
في ذات الملف ورغم نجاح تصويت ولايه كنز
ضد ازاله حق الاجهاض ووصفه بالاستفتاء على
قوه المراه الامريكيه وعدم اضعافها الا ان
مساحه التفاؤل التي احاطت بالديمقراطيين
بامكانيه تغيير المساج العام في الولايه
الحمراء قبيله الانتخابات النصفيه يحذر
منها البعض لا سيما ان الاجهاض قضيه
خلافيه
رياح ونسيتيه تهب باتجاه مصلحه
الديمقراطيين في ولايه كنزه الامريكيه
اعطتهم امالا بازاله الصبغه الجمهوريه
الحمراء عنها للمره الثانيه على الاقل
بمنصب الحاكم
في الولايه الغربيه ورغم تصويتها مرتين
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب الا ان
الحاكمه الديمقراطيه لوراكيلي انتزعت فوزا
صعبا فيها قبل اربع سنوات
على قضيه الاجهاض لا سيما اننا خبيكانزس
رفضوا باغلبيه ساحقه في اغسطس الماضي
ازاله الحمايه الدستوريه للولايه لحقوق
الاجهاض
على الجانب الجمهوري طموح حذرا بتخليص
الولايه من الديمقراطيين واعادتها لصفهم
من خلال مرشحهم المدعي العام داريكشميد
وعوده قائمه على الدفاع عن الحريه الدينيه
ومحاربه الجريمه ومعارضه الاجهاض وفي ظهره
دعم قوي من الرئيس السابق لا سيما ان
الانتخابات النصفيه لهذا العام بيئه اقل
احتضانا نسبيا للمحافظين
على طويله المنافسه في مفارقه غريبه في
قلب حمله الحاكمه الديمقراطيه صوره جمعتها
بالرئيس السابق بالاشهر الاولى من جاء حتى
كورونا لتؤكد من خلالها وضع السياسه
الحزبيه جانبا للتركيز على الانسب لكانزا
هذا هو يحاول ترامب تحفيز قاعدته
الانتخابيه والحفاظ عليها طمعا باصوات
كنزس السته بالمجمع الانتخابي في حال
ترشحه لانتخابات الرئاسه مع الاخذ
بالاعتبار ان الولايه تميل الى الجمهوريين
بشكل كبير ولم تصوت ديمقراطي في البيت
الابيض منذ عام 1964
[موسيقى]
معنا من واشنطن بيان غانم مراسل العربيه
يعني في هذه المعركه الطاحنه هناك ولايتان
بارستان نتحدث عن بنسلفانيا وعن جورجيا
سابدا من بنسلفانيا التي لها يعني كلمه
الفصل بيدفى حول من سيكون
في مجلس الشيوخ كيف هي المعركه هناك وهل
العنصر الديني هو اساس
المعركه في بنسلفانيا غريبه السبب يعود في
ذلك الى ان المرشحين لمنصب مجلس الشيوخ
يتقاربان جدا في الارقام هناك مرشح من قبل
اديمقراطيين وهو فتر من هو مرشح من قبل
الجمهوريين وهو ناموس والفرق بينهما لا
يتعدى النقطه مره
لصالح
الغريب في هذا الموضوع هو ان هذه الولايه
تقريبا تحسب معركه حاكم الولايه وهي تشبه
تماما المعركه على مقعد مجلس الشيوخ
المرشح الديمقراطي متقدم جدا فيما المرشح
الجمهوري متاخر جدا لذلك نقول ان
الانتخابات في هذه الولايات غريبه جدا
لها كلمه فصل كيف هي المعركه
تشبه تماما
بنسلفانيا ولكن مع فارق مهم جدا المرشح
لمنصب الحاكم هو احد معارضي الرئيس ترامب
ومع ذلك هو يتقدم على منافسته الديمقراطيه
وهي افريقيا سوداء
بسته او سبع نقاط وبالتالي يستطيع هذا
المرشح الجمهوري ان ينتصر في هذه المعركه
من دون اي دعم من الرئيس السابق دولار
ترامب في الوقت ذاته المرشحان لمنصب مجلس
الشيوخ هرج الوكر والمبشر
يتقدمين على بعضهما فقط بنقاط قليله
والمعركه ليست محسومه شكرا لك يا كابتن
غانم مراسل العربيه حدثنا منه
[موسيقى]
من وسط المحيط الهادئ جزر سليمان تتحول
الى ملعب التنافس الدولي في شقه سياسيه
والعسكري بين الصين والولايات المتحده
التي ترى فيها مركزا استراتيجيا مهما يمكن
ان تستغله بكين لصالحها فمع زياده التوتر
في المحيط الهادي بشان جزيره تايوان يعود
للواجهه ملف جزر سليمان في مشهد يعكس
انقسام البلاد بين الصين والدول الغربيه
والسبب هو الاتفاقيه الامنيه الموقعه بين
الطرفين والتي حولت البلاد لبؤره صراع
دوليه واقليميه بين كل من واشنطن وبكين
التي تسعى لتعزيز وجودها العسكري خارج
ارضها حيث اكد مراقبون ان المخاوف الغربيه
تصاعدت منذ ان ان حازت جزر سليمان
دبلوماسيا الى تايوان من تايوان الى الصين
في عام 2019 وقامت بتسريب مسوده اتفاقيه
امنيه قدم
في جزر من المحيط الهادئ الواقعه على
مقربه من استراليا والتي صاحبها في
التاسعه عشر من شهر ابريل الماضي اتفاق
امني اقلق القوى الغربيه لانه يمهد الطريق
نحو وجود عسكري صيني جنوب المحيط الهادئ
وايضا عسكر جزر بحر الصين الجنوبي ومراقبه
وتتبع للقوات الامريكيه وعلى الرغم من
سريات بنود الاتفاقيه وتاكيد الصين عدم
وجود مساءا لانشاء قاعده عسكريه الا ان
واشنطن توعدت بالرد بشكل حاسم في حاله
حدوث ذلك في اشاره الى ان الصين قد تحتاج
الى جزر سليمان في انشاء قاعده عسكريه
لاستخدامها في اجتياح تايوان من عده جبهات
ويظهر الخلاف بين الغرب والصين في داخل
جزر سليمان
جزيره ماليتا مناقشات حول خطط معه واشنطن
لتطوير ميناء في اعماق البحر بينما
تابع المصالح الصينيه خطط التنميه في
جزيره
غوادالكانال الرئيسيه حيث تقع العاصمه في
مشهد يعكس طبعا انقسام البلاد بين الصين
والدول الغربيه وطبعا كل هذا التنافس نظرا
لاهميه جزر سليمان الجيو سياسييا
[موسيقى]
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بعد عقدين من الغائه مشروع قانون التجنيد
الاجباري يثير جدلا من جديد في العراق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى شرم الشيخ بمصر وقمه
المناخ كوب تونس 7 ومن المتوقع ان يشهد
جدلا فيها بشان ما اذا كان يتعين على دول
الغنيه دفع تعويضات للدول الفقيره
المتضرره من الكوارث الناجمه عن تغيير
المناخ بدوره حذر الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو جوتيرش من انبعاثات
الغازات المسببه للاحتباس الحراري اخذه في
التزايد بشكل غير مصروف
كابتن
قمه المناخ هو المكان المناسبه لاعاده
بناء الثقه واعاده تاسيس الطموح اللازم
لتجنب كوكبنا كارثه مناخيه في الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه تلقينا تقريرا تلو الاخر
يوضح الصوره القادمه لا تزال الانبعاثات
تتزايد عند مستويات قياسيه بدلا من
الانخفاض بنسبه 45% بحلول عام 2030
انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري في طريقه
الان للارتفاع بنسبه 10% وفي الوقت نفسه
فان الدرجات الحراره في طريقها للارتفاع
بما يصل الى درجتين فاصله ثمانيه مع اتباع
السياسات الحاليه بحلول نهايه القرن سيبقى
المناخ الى الابد في ارتفاعه كارثه بدرجات
الحراره
كايو صغيره
[موسيقى]
والان مشاهدينا الى شرم الشيخ والزميله
رنده ابو العزم مراسله العربيه التي
ستحاور السفير وائل ابو المجد الممثل
الرسمي لرئيس مؤتمر كابتن اليك راندا
شكرا
وائل ابو المجد اليوم هو اليوم الاول
يعني يوم كان مزدحم جدا بجداول الاعمال
يعني
محادثات ومفاوضات ما اهم النقاط التي يمكن
ان نقول قد احرزنا فيها تقدما مع انه
اليوم الاول هو اليوم الاول بيشهد في
حقيقه الامر اعتماد جدول الاعمال وده
بيكون يوم رغم انه يبدو امر روتيني الا
انه دائما شديد الصعوبه لانه بيتم الاتفاق
فيه على جدول اعمال المؤتمر بكامله
وبيتضمن البنود الجديده التي رات بعض
الدول اضافتها لجدول الاعمال اهم البنود
طبعا كل البنود المتعلقه بالتمويل والتكيف
والتخفيف وكل هذه الامور متراده عليها
ولكن هناك جنود جديده وكان ابرازها واهمها
بند متعلق بقضيه اسمها الاضرار والخسائر
وتم مساله قديمه جدا جدا ولم ينجح اي
مؤتمر في ادراج اصلا للنقا تمويل الاضرار
والخسائر يعني كانت زميلتي ليال كانت قد
ذكرت هل ستدفع الدول المتقدمه تعويضات
للدول الناميه التي تضررت من الخسائر
بسببها
لتمويل دون الاقرار بمسؤوليه قانونيه فهو
ده الكان بيت الاصيل الذي حال دول طوال
السنوات الماضيه دون تحقيق اي تقدم في
الدول المتقدمه لن تقبل بمسؤوليه قانونيه
تفتح ابواب تريليونات من الدولارات من
التعويضه
يمكن عنوان جريده الجارديا على انه دائما
الرؤساء والقاده والمشاركين
بيتحدثوا بطريقه ايجابيه جدا وكلها امل
ولكن عند التفاوض بيكون هناك احباط شديد
ما الذي نتوقع لا نتوقع ونامل وندفع كدوله
رئاسه الصديقه المؤتمر ان تتحول الكلمات
والتصريحات والوعود والتعهدات الى حقيقه
على الارض بمعنى انه في غرف المفاوضات نرى
نفس هذه الروح الايجابيه ولكن ايضا على
ارض التنفيذ احنا سمينا المؤتمر هذا العام
مؤتمر التنفيذ بمعنى انه حان الوقت من
الانتقال من المفاوضات والوعود الى
التنفيذ برامج ومشروعات تحدث اثرا لتخفيف
وط- التغير المناخ على ارض الواقع اليه
تقرر في هذا المؤتمر لا المؤتمرات لا تقرر
اليات محدده بالضروره فوريه لان ده اطار
قانوني تفاوض ولكن على الى جوار العمليه
الحكوميه التفاؤوليه هناك جانب العمليات
التنفيذيه هذا يحدث في الايام المواضيعيه
والمبادرات التي تطرح وفي حالات ايضا
القمه الرئاسيه تشهد حضور حوالين مئه رئيس
دوله وسيجتمع حول موائد مستديره لمناقشه
مختلفه القضايا التي طرحناها عليهم
بمشاركه المجتمع المدني ورجال اعمال
ومؤسسات تمويل دوليه يعني بياتي هذا
المؤتمر ايضا في صراعات جيوس سياسيه حرب
روسيا واوكرانيا يعني هناك مواضيع كثيره
جدا مواضيع تخص بعض الدول مشكله سد النهضه
بالنسبه لمصر وجبنا رئيس وزراء اثيوبيا
هنا في مصر اليوم وجدنا يعني لن يحضر رئيس
بوتن لن يحضر رئيس الصيني لن يحضر رئيس
الهندي ولكن وجدنا رئيس الامريكي وبعدين
همم اتي لرؤساء عدد كبير من الدول
الاوروبيه مشاركه كبيره جدا هل همم يعني
نعلم ان هناك خشيه من انتقال همم الصراعات
الجيو السياسيه الى هذا المؤتمر كيف يمكن
ان تحكمون هذا بالفعل قضيه تغير المناخ
اللي انت تنتظر احددا ولابد من العمل بجد
وبتفاني وبيتفاهم للوصول الى المخرجات
التي نتطلع اليها وقف هذا الخطر الداهم
الذي يهدد المستقبل للحياه على هذا الكوكب
وبالتالي لا بد من تحت الجهود وجود
الرؤساء يعطي زخم سياسي وهيحضر في اكثر من
100 رئيس دوله ولكن حقيقه الامر ان
المفاوضات هي بيت القصيد الدعم السياسي
ياتي من رؤساء ولكن مفاوضات تحتاج الى روح
ايجابيه فقد مضت هذه المحاضرات على ماده
30 سنه بشكل يعني صعب جدا جدا يسعى كل طرف
الى تقليل الالتزاماته والوفاء باقل قدر
من التعهدات لابد من الانتقال لمرحله
التنفيذ لان الخطر دائم ولن يرحم احد
بنشكر حياتنا جدا نتمنى لكم طبعا ونتمنى
التوفيق للعالم كله لان هي ليس مؤتمر لمصر
ولكنه مؤتمر العالم
ابو العزم من شرم الشيخ
بتزامني مع قمه المناخ الهواء في نيودلهي
العاصمه الاكثر تلوثا في العالم يشكل خطرا
شديدا على صحه الانسان ما جعل السلطات
الهنديه تغلق المصانع ومواقع البناء وتقيد
حركه المركبات للسيطره على الضباب الدخاني
الذي يلف افق منطقه العاصمه
[موسيقى]
طائره مسيره تركيه سياره تابعه لعناصر
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في مدينه القامشلي
قرب الحدود السوريه التركيه وذكر مراسل
العربيه ان القصف ادى لمقتل شخصين واصابه
ثلاثه وذلك قرب الحزام الغربي لمدينه
القرش
من سوريا الى العراق حيث يثير قانون خدمه
العلم الجدل داخل الاوساط الشبابيه
العراقيه بين الرفض والقبول الامر الذي
انعكس على الكتل البرلمانيه داخل مجلس
النواب ليتم سحب هذا القانون وقراءته من
اجونده جلسه اليوم بسبب الخلف الخلافات
والضغوط فل نتابع ما حدث
خالد الشاب والثلاثيين والذي يعمل في محل
لبيع الملابس يرى في قانون خدمه العالم
ضروره لمعالجه مشاكل الشباب وعلى راسها
البطاله ولذي بموجبه سيكون على كل شاب بلغ
18 من عمره الالتحاق بالجيش مع عوده
التجنيد الزامي انا ايد هذا الشيء اليوم
احنا هذا المفروض احنا لازم سابقا احنا
نسوي لهذا الشيء لان دول العالم
هسه احنا شبابنا يعني مع الاسف عندهم خمول
عندهم
كسل بالموضوع وهذا الشيء يسوي
الشاب همم زلمه
وبنفس الوقت تتحد الاطراف كليتها ويصير
عنده حس وطني اكثر
رغم وجودي مؤيدين للقانون لكن احمد ومعه
اخرين يرون فيه تبديدا لاحلامهم وطموحاتهم
في التوظيف والحياه الرغيده هو طبعا ظنينا
ان يصيبه احنا كما مثلا خمس سنوات نداوم
الطب مثلا تكمل يعني ظلت تدور والله على
الدوره وتعال تجنيد وما عرف شنو يعني تدور
تريد تعيين تدور مثلا تريد تشوف المستقبل
جهات سياسيه تمثل مناطق شمال وغرب العراق
رحبت بالقانون معتبره الخدمه الالزاميه
عاملا لتعزيز روح المواطنه والقضاء على
البطاله لكن الاجنحه السياسيه للفصائل
المسلحه اعتبرت القانون يستهدف نفوذها
ويقلص حجم تاثيرها امنيا في البلاد جميع
الفصائل المسلحه
والمنظمات الاجراميه تخشى وجود جيش
قوي متمكن يستطيع محاسبتها اذا ما خرجت عن
اداره وسيطره القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه
حتما معنويا همم تصبح القوات المسلحه اكثر
استعدادا وتاهلا لمحاسبه الخارجين على
القانون
الجدل هنا لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد بل تعداه
الى سحب قراءه القانون من جدول الاعمال و
تاجيله للدراسه بحسب لجنه الامن والدفاع
النيابيه الانقسام الشعبي بين التاييد
والرفض للقانون انعكس بشكل مباشر على
الكتل النيابيه وضعها في حرج من امرها
وربما يجبرها لاحقا على اعاده النظر في
ترحيب مجددا داخل اروقه البرلمان سامر
الكبيسي العربيه بغداد
[موسيقى]
طلب كبير ولا زال يتصاعد على سوق المكاتب
الفاخره في الرياضيات يتزامن مع افتتاح
شركات عالميه لما قراتها في الرياض
احد المشاريع العقاريه التي جذبت العديد
من الشركات الطبيه لتصبح اول قريه طبيه
مصغره بالعاصمه
اصبح هذا المشهد الاحتفالي في مدينه
الرياض خلال الاشهر الماضيه اعتياديا نظرا
لكثره نقل الشركات العالميه مقراتها
وافتتاح مكاتب لها في العاصمه مجعله هنالك
الطلب عالي على سوق المكاتب لا سيما من
فئه الف
على ايقاع العرضه النجديه يحتفل رئيس
التنفيذي لشركه الادويه السويسريه روج
بافتتاح مقر شركه
بحضور وزير الاستثمار خالد الفالح في
ليسون فالي حيث تجتمع اكثر من 50 شركه
عالميه واقليميه غالبيتها في القطاع الطبي
اهميه الانتقال
للعاصمه الرياض وافتتاح
بواسط الرياض اليوم له اهميه لشركه راش
اليوم واعطاء الرساله الواضحه
باهميه الراس من الاستثمار بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه لحتى هل هل نوفيشن
والابتكارات الجديده اللي همم بتطلع من رش
تكون موجوده باثر على وقت للمرضى سميت
المنطقه التي جذبت الشركات الدوليه بالاسم
ثاني ايامنا باسم الوادي الشهير ليسن الذي
اصبح تحفه معماريه في قلب الرياض اتخذته
الشركات الطبيه هو المستشفيات مقر لها على
مساحه
1500 متر مربع اخترنا هذا الموقع همم
للاكسس سبيليتي او الوصول السهل فيها شفنا
انه المكان هذا ممكن يكون قريب من شركائنا
من المستشفيات ومن الوزارات والوصول له
بشكل افضل وكذلك المجمع يوفر بيئه جميله
للموظفين يوفر خدمات جميله للموظفين وشفنا
انه قد يكون هذا افضل مكان نحط فيه المكتب
الرئيسي والحمد لله اتوقع انه توفقنا فيه
الطلب لا زال يتصاعدوا على قطاع المكاتب
الفاخره بعد انعام خلال السنوات الماضيه
منعكس على جوده المشاريع مثل وادي الليل
ليسن الذي يتوقعوا ان يصبح رافدا اقتصاديا
لمدينه الرياض عبد المحسن الحربي العربي
الرياض
بعث مفوضه الامم المتحده سامي لحقوق
الانسان برساله مفتوحه الى الى ماسك الملك
الجديد لشركه وتريحه فيها على ضمان ان
تكون حقوق الانسان شيئا اساسيا بالنسبه
لاداره التوتر واشار المفوض السامي في
رسالته الى تويتر الذي يعتبر جزء من ثروه
عالميه غير طريقه التواصل في العالم
الافتراضي والرقمي
استعرض سلاح الجو الصينيه الطائره
المقاتله شبح من الجيل الخامس جي تواني
افضل طائره مقاتله في الصين لاول مره
للجمهور
[موسيقى]
بنزين
ستعرض القوات الجويه انجازاتها التاريخيه
في العقد الماضي وانجازاتها المرحليه في
تحديث القوه الجويه الاستراتيجيه وسوف
تروي القوات الجويه قصصها عن تعزيز الجيش
من خلال العمل الجاد والتطوير مبتكر
والانفتاح والثقه والامتنان للشعب
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
بمدافع عن ودبابات الغربيه الجيش
الاوكراني يحشد على تخومه
واشنطن تدفع اكياس للتفاوض مع موسكو
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه في الميدان اطلاق
نار على المتظاهرين وفي البرلمان مطالبات
باعدام المشاركين
48 ساعه على بدء الانتخابات النصفيه في
الولايات المتحده شعبيه اوباما لانقاذ
الديمقراطيين وترامب يعدو بفوز جمهوري
كبير